PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: Welcome back.
Today we're incredibly lucky to be joined by Rene Almeling.
Renee is a professor of Sociology and Public Health at Yale University
and she's one of the world's leading experts
on the market for sperm and egg.
Rene, thank you so much for joining us.
DR. RENE ALMELING: It's a pleasure to be here.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: So Rene, you're an expert on the buying
and selling of sperm and egg, sometimes also referred to as gametes.
And we're going to talk a little bit about those two markets.
And we're going to start by talking just a bit about sperm.
So tell me a little bit, who's the typical sperm donor in America?
DR. RENE ALMELING: The average sperm donor is a college student.
He's in his early 20s.
He's interested IN making a little bit of extra money
at a job that doesn't take too much of his time.
When I did interviews with sperm donors, I
found that there were really two groups.
There was this group of sort of younger college students.
There was also a group of older men who had
known somebody who experienced trouble getting pregnant or infertility.
And so some of those folks had sort of put in some of their energy
into being sperm donors as well.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And a lot of this is from your amazing book,
Sex Cells, C-E-L-L-S, which I think is one of the best titles I've seen
on the academic market.
How much is the typical sperm donor paid in America?
DR. RENE ALMELING: Well, the average payment is about $100, $125 per sample.
What most people don't know about sperm banks
is that men go through an extensive screening process.
And then they're going in at least once a week for six months to a year
in order to earn that $100 to $125 per sample.
So we have this idea that men can wake up one morning
and say, oh, I'm going to go donate sperm this morning, and go make $50.
And that's not really how it works.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And so the screening screens out a lot of men.
Any sense about how many men get screened out?
I have to say for my class, when I taught this in a bricks and mortar
class once, I tried to become a sperm donor.
I was screened out.
I don't know that says about me.
Am I normal to have been screened out?
What kind of number of people get screened out?
DR. RENE ALMELING: Well, you're in very good company.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: Thank goodness.
DR. RENE ALMELING: So about 99% of men who apply to become sperm donors
will be screened out.
So sperm banks are looking for men who are extremely
fertile with very high sperm count.
So if you look at that sort of bell curve of fertility,
they're looking for men in the top 2% to 3% of sperm count.
That's because they freeze the sperm or cryopreserve it.
That kills off about half the cells.
So that's right there knocking out most men who apply.
And then the men who make it through that test
need three generations of their family health history to look pretty good.
So men who have a lot of heart attacks or mental illness
or alcoholism in their family won't make it through the screening process.
And then they have to be willing to go in at least
once a week for a year to make donations.
And so you know if you have 100 men who make that first call to the sperm bank,
you're really walking out the door with about 1% of the people
making it through that process.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: So there's a lot of screening that happens.
And I know you've written your work about how men are paid.
So just because I donate sperm, does that mean I automatically
get paid for that donation?
DR. RENE ALMELING: No, it doesn't.
So in sperm banks, men go in and they make this donation.
If their sperm count is high enough to meet the bank's standards,
then they will be paid for that donation.
But all kinds of things can cause that sperm count to drop, including
being too stressed out, say by your finals in school.
If you're drinking too much alcohol, if you're not getting enough rest,
if you're sick, so all of these things can cause sperm count to drop.
So men's sperm count, which-- another thing that people don't realize
is men's sperm count really fluctuates over days and months.
And so sperm donors have to stay pretty healthy
and take good care of themselves in order to actually make
that money from being a donor.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And there's also an abstinence requirement
as I understand it.
DR. RENE ALMELING: Yes.
So men who donate sperm because they need to build up that sperm count,
have to be abstinent from any sort of sexual activity for about 48 hours
before they go donate.
So then you can start to understand how sperm donors find this a little bit
onerous.
They have to schedule their sex lives.
They have to be mindful of their diet and their exercise.
And so if they're going in to donate once a week,
then they're being abstinent for two days before they go in.
If they're trying to donate twice a week,
then they're abstinent for two days twice a week.
And some of the donors I interviewed tried to donate three times a week.
So then they're really sort of really scheduling their sex lives in a way
that many of them did find somewhat onerous.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And I should say
that although we're using the term donation, that's
the common term, as both of us have written about in our work,
there's lots of controversy about whether that's the right term.
Some people prefer provision, which is more neutral.
Some people like to say sale, because it is kind of being compensated,
at least the portion that we're talking about.
And we'll keep using the word donation because it's more natural.
But always good to kind of acknowledge the way
in which these terms carry meaning.
DR. RENE ALMELING: It's an interesting point,
and there has been a lot of debate in the literature as you note.
For me as a sociologist, I'm really interested in how this industry thinks
of itself and how it works.
And so it's important to me that the term that they use is donation.
And then of course we can sit here and say,
well you're being paid for donation, and a paid donation
seems a little oxymoronic.
But I think it's important to understand why they use that language,
how that language functions in organizing the market
and shaping donors experiences.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And this leads into the question
about how men are recruited.
So how are sperm donors recruited?
What's the messaging about sperm donation?
Tell me a little bit more about that.
DR. RENE ALMELING: Well historically, sperm banks really relied on this idea
that sperm donation was this easy thing.
It's something that's a little bit funny.
They make jokes in their advertisements.
And so the advertisements really focus on cartoon images of sperm.
There might be some small print about helping somebody to become a family.
But the focus is really on, come in and get
paid for something you're already doing, to quote one of the ads.
So they draw on these sort of cheeky advertisements in order to recruit men
in, because they're dealing with the college age population for the most
part.
But donation is not really framed for men
as something that is important or really contributing to the lives of others
by helping them have families.
The focus really is on, come in and provide some sperm and get paid.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: So let's talk a little about the way
in which these men are recruited and in particular,
sort of gendered messaging in recruitment
and the conceptions of employment.
This is a really important part of your work right now.
DR. RENE ALMELING: Really the main argument of my book
is that the language of donations suffuses both the world of egg agencies
and sperm banks.
But in sperm banks a paid donation is understood as a job.
They think of men as employees.
They cut them paychecks every two weeks.
They talk to them about this is something
they need to show up for on a regular basis, clock in and clock out,
and produce a passable sample.
And in egg donation, that paid donation is really
understood as a gift from one woman to another,
and that it's a gift in the service of creating a family.
So even though this language of donation is
similar across the sperm donation and egg donation, what the donation is
looks really different.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: How long do men typically stay sperm donors?
DR. RENE ALMELING: We actually don't have any data to answer that question.
So one of the things that I think we'll probably talk about later
is the fact that this market is completely unregulated in the United
States.
We have no idea how many donors there are,
how often they donate, how many children are born.
So those basic questions, we actually don't have the answers to.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And let me just emphasize that last point
you said that we don't know how many children are born.
There are no regulations.
So in theory, there is no limit to the number of children that
could be born from a certain donor.
Now, many of the clinics will say that they're responsible about this.
They keep registries, although there's some question about whether people can
go to more than one registry, right?
DR. RENE ALMELING: Right.
Well, sperm banks do ask their clients to report back
if they have a pregnancy, if they give birth to a child,
so that they can keep track of how many offspring have been born per donor.
But they don't have any way of enforcing that reporting.
And there's also no standards or regulations
for what the maximum is for that family.
So we now have websites like DonorSiblingRegistry.com
where people can go and see that particular donor
from a particular sperm bank has 40 offspring who have registered just
with that website, or 75 or 175.
So we do have some of these anecdotal reports
of very large numbers of children being born from particular donors.
And that to me is one of the major things
that we do need to rectify in this market.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: One of the concerns
is what is sometimes called accidental incest, that you might actually
end up having a romantic relationship with a half sibling at least, right?
DR. RENE ALMELING: Yeah.
I think that is definitely one of the theoretical concerns that
has been out there.
I'm actually more concerned about the health effects.
Because a lot of these donors are young college students
and they may have genetic mutations that will cause disease later in life
that they may not know about.
And so there have been cases such as one that
was reported in The Journal of the American Medical Association
with a donor who didn't realize that he had this heart condition that
was genetic.
It was a heritable condition.
He was a sperm donor.
He had 22 children, and six or seven of those kids
inherited that mutation, including a toddler who died from it.
So in old fashioned, normal reproduction,
you know men could certainly have two or five or even eight or 10 children,
but when we ramp up the numbers as we have
with sperm donation, those unknown health risks that get passed on,
get passed on to a potentially much larger number of children.
PROFESSOR I. GLENN COHEN: And we'll actually
talk about a case later in the course about a child who
inherits polycystic kidney disease and tries
to track down the identity of the sperm donor for that purpose.